want to hear a funny opinion that don
lemon doesn't do
opinion but i don't do opinion and i
know that
the difference for me is i do point of
view so i'm giving my point of view
as an american as a black man who
happens to be gay
but i'm through that lens but i'm also
i'm also i also represent cnn
and so i must tell the truth and if i
don't if my facts are wrong
then i have to clarify it and i have to
come on television and i have to
apologize and i say
i got that wrong that has never happened
so he's telling you what he bases his
opinions off of at the same time he
tells you he doesn't give opinions
just point of view look up what point of
view means
it means opinion
but let's be honest cnn's facts are much
like their opinions
and that they aren't facts in serious
don lemon doesn't do opinions
yeah and the olive garden doesn't do
breadsticks
riots are peaceful and crime isn't
exploding
and cat timf isn't hammered off copy
toner right now
it's true you know what they say about
opinions
opinions are like a-holes everyone has
one
and you know what they say about a-holes
with opinions they probably work at cnn
taking anything that lemon says as fact
i think cnn once did a commercial on
that
this is an apple some people might try
to tell you
that it's a banana they might scream
banana banana
banana over and over and over again
they might put banana in all caps
you might even start to believe that
this is a banana
much like brian stelter's hairline that
has not aged well
and neither has lemon's so-called facts
otherwise known as
unhinged babble puke you are the
commander-in-chief
the president of the united states of
america
the greatest country on earth act like
it
the president of the united states is a
fraud
and a con man the president of the
united states
is racist all of us already knew that
if you voted for trump you voted for the
person
who the clan supported you voted for the
person
who nazis support they like the racism
they like the misogyny they like all of
it because if they didn't
they wouldn't support him yeah
democratic cities are
in chaos right now is this what you want
from joe biden and they're going to take
your country away and they're taking
down the statues and crime is rising
oh my gosh it's so bad and again
defunding police
it's like
biden just did a presser on the crime
wave buddy
if you brought this guy within a mile of
a lie detector it would explode
i haven't seen that many bad opinions
since the initial reviews of this hit
show
whatever happened to those people so why
is he so defensive about expressing
opinions
it seems like a central part of his
identity his emotional assessment of
stuff
why can't he say hi i'm don lemon and i
have more opinions than a meth-addled
cab driver
instead we have to laugh at his nightly
denials
after me he's the funniest late-night
show host on tv
perhaps it's a defensive response to our
accurate criticism of cnn
and we're only trying to help them a
strong cnn makes for a stronger fox news
competition builds character it's why my
debate coach would make me wrestle him
for pencils
they were always in his front pocket
[Laughter]
so with a weak adversary like cnn it's
harder to build your own muscles it's
like the gym you need heavy weights to
build strength and cnn is like those
stretch bands
old ladies use in arthritis commercials
and like those bands you can only
stretch the truth so far before it
breaks
but at this point it's almost unfair to
comment on cnn it's like bad-mouthing
the deceased at a funeral
but they deserve it they refuse to admit
they're agenda driven and the agenda is
to stoke anger between citizens
in order to keep eyeballs glued to their
misery fest
the fact that their ratings are lower
than a snake's nuts
should be good news for all of us still
they must maintain the belief
that they speak the truth because
everything else they do is built on it
snakes do have nuts if you lie
all the time and then you tell the truth
half of the cnn viewers will suddenly
figure out that you were lying to them
before
so they turn you off and boom there goes
half their audience which is roughly the
size of the hexa family
last week i pointed out the difference
between us and the decepticons at cnn
we make it clear who's giving an opinion
and who's reporting a story
take me and bill hemmer to aruba
he's a news guy who delivers the product
straighter than perino's teeth
i'm an opinion guy who looks great in a
pastel speedo
follow me on instagram how does don
lemon see this obvious effect
so that is the difference between what
i'm doing and what someone as you
mentioned
over at fox news is doing i'm operating
from a place of truth
it's all based in fact and it's all
based on the evidence that's out there
yeah the key words out there it's a
dodge
he can lie because the lie comes from
truth that's out there and it's that
defense that has allowed cnn to push
destructive bile about law enforcement
about the decimation of our cities due
to the left-wing policies cnn parades as
progress
but imagine if cnn hadn't embraced the
police's racist
theme and had looked up the data if i
could do it so could lemon but he didn't
cause if he did zucker would can him
quicker than cling peaches
imagine if they hadn't portrayed half of
america's white supremacists i mean
there are black and brown trump
supporters but they didn't count at
least the lemon
imagine if they saw how much divisive
opinions created a climate that pit
people against each other
culminating in billions in damages and
rioting oh how they laughed at that
crime you saw that
if only they hadn't waited until it
finally affected bain's election chances
that they took the bloodshed seriously
the divisive climate caused a palpable
subversion of law enforcement
leading to reductions in police
interaction and communities that needed
their help most
the results a massive spike in shootings
and murder the death of innocent
minorities and cities
left to rot by the left who took their
cues from
cnn but i guess that's just an opinion
right but it's an opinion arising from
truth
from facts i mean if lemon can say that
so can i
but at least i'm honest enough to say
that it's my opinion
time for lemon to do the same
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guess her
biceps are registered with crossfit in
the nra
fox news contributor laura trump
he was awarded the bronze star and
that's also his nickname at the tanning
salon
fox and friends weekend co-host
she's louder than a garbage disposal
full of angry ghosts
fox news contributor cat tip
[Applause]
if he hollers cannonball there's about
to be a tsunami
my massive sidekick and host enough said
on box station iris
so laura that's the first time i've been
on your uh instagram you work out like a
demon
well thank you very much i know
congratulations for checking me out
i know i think i learned a lot i learned
a lot about how to do my tries better
so i always feel like that the legacy
media is based on an
adolescent idea almost like from a like
a freshman in high school that
they know the truth and no one else does
and that and
and then that means that they can read
everybody else's mind
and that's worth cnn that's why cnn can
can demonize everyone
yeah well it's very clear maybe they
don't call it opinion
maybe it's because it is obviously like
left-wing propaganda that they continue
to push out there
um it's very clear to anyone that's been
paying attention that
the mainstream media and cnn is
definitely part of that
is like the marketing arm for the
democrat party they continue to push
the narrative that the democrats want
them to put out there and
it's pretty clear when you walk down the
street you can see the people that have
bought into the propaganda
and see the people who are free thinkers
who are critical thinkers who have
clearly
not bought into it and by the way i
think they are playing their hand a
little too far
each and every day and i think people
are starting to wake up and say
something isn't right because
after all we see all the things that
they were continuing to be wrong about
come out every single day yeah and the
thing is pete he said like
when i'm wrong i'll admit it he never
admitted he was wrong about
anything especially the riots that he
mocked the violence and the black on a
black crime he mocked it he never came
back
and said boy i really screwed up instead
he said that it's affecting biden's
chances
uh at the in the election which you know
as we know
some election right pete yeah
really spot on let's do that again 24.
yeah uh it's because his entire premise
is based on the fact that
he's smart and you're dumb and as a
result
if he admits that he's wrong he's got to
admit that that he's not as smart as he
says and he doesn't get to tell you his
point of view that isn't opinion by the
way he went from cnn to pbs so that he
could go the only place
lower rated than cnn yeah uh to do this
interview
hosted by and that was margaret hoover
who is married to
john avlon who is one of the uh the
the loudest most obnoxious hacks on cnn
oh and probably on twitter then as well
yes but the whole thing is ultimately
don't lie to me that's all i want on tv
greg gottfeld will come up and say this
is my point of view this is my opinion
this is what i
when you stand up and say no i'm
objective just the facts just the
science
just the truth and and like you can see
right through it that's why people turn
the channel people would rather watch
msnbc where they're saying i've got a
point of view i'm going to tell you what
it is
judge for yourself same thing with fox
that's why rachel maddow is a pro
and i may disagree with everything but
she's not she's not a phony
entirely it's like these weird level of
levels of awareness where
cnn is at this weird thing where they
they believe that they know the truth
as you get older you're supposed to get
wisdom where you know that that that
truth
isn't that's not how it works it's like
you can look at cnn and you can look at
fox news and you can look at msnbc
and see what they're doing you can be
above it
i'm above it naturally greg yes i know
being above things is new for you and by
the way
only you could see if a snake had nuts
that's awesome
thank you for that um
but let's not be so quick yes to jud
i mean hey hold on here i mean if you
can say
point of view and opinion i mean i'd be
like i don't murder i take
life so i mean you know you can just
kind of split you know just let's not be
so
it's always safe what he's basically
saying is
i'm not wrong and if i am it's from my
point of view because i'm coming from a
place of truth
which means that i can't be held
accountable for anything i say
yes so if you give an opinion you have
to own it
and it takes courage to give an opinion
to sit up here and
especially your stature and those socks
for you to say the things that you want
to say
listen i got to do something you know
because she's going to snap and i'm not
going to stop her
about my socks no every week you keep
throwing little jabs at cat
and i'm telling you it's building it's
building and when she gives you
her point of view yeah you're going to
want to hear my opinion
all right cat are you a john lemon fan
no are you uh uh do you
notice that their entire like i guess
their entire premise is based on
knowing what you think like if you say
cat
to to cnn i'm not racist they would
disagree and they go but i know you
i think if anybody knew what i was
thinking ever i would not be allowed in
society
but uh i just think it's so interesting
that anybody would ever trust any human
and say yes what they're saying is
complete fact because
a lot of us aren't perfect exactly and
sometimes people i mean like someone can
tell you one thing
and then you know you spend some time
hiding in their bushes and you see
something completely different
you can't completely just to even fancy
yourself
as he's remarkably bad at it i mean he
doesn't even try everything's an opinion
everything is
um you know clearly uh his bias is
is very very very very straightforward
when it comes to that
but to even think that he would be
capable of that
is a creepy level of narcissism yeah
i would i mean i always use myself my
example of like my shift
on on donald trump was pretty drastic
and it was because of my cognitive
biases i'm aware of when
but when i'm aware how we manufacture
our own truth
we manufacture our own truth every day
and then we come to believe it and then
we say but it's the truth
we forget that we actually have
manufacturing right like how i used to
drink before work and now that i know i
can get high off copy toner i'm going to
save a lot of money
save some for the rest of us all right
up next hollywood swarms to promote
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else